what's up guys mm-hmm hopefully you guys
can hear me that's not good think about
it
well I'll give you one second guys okay
you should be better now a bit louder
well if like I make it like a funny
louder
yeah microphone about as a lot as it's
gonna get I think unless no it's turned
up all the way over here
drink more water
oh man okay so you should hear through
you shouldn't hear through one headphone
if you hear a headphone if you have that
phones on you shouldn't hear they're
just one headphone here I you should be
able to hear through both that was one
of the mistakes I made in the last one I
should have just stereo instead of mono
so it should be it should be better
yeah the movie was really good yeah
that's blowing out Chad always blows up
whenever I do live streams it's kind of
crazy the audio still kind of low let's
see you have the mic audio set to 100%
so I can't make the money I can't make
the microphone audio any louder at least
not to my knowledge hold on properties
oh hold on I might be able to all right
let me know if that sounds any better
there's that many louder for you guys
hopefully it's not crazy loud but the
audio is fine okay okay audios fine for
most people all right all right yeah
this is the this is the Marvel villains
shirt it's kind of cool it's just all of
it all the different villains from oval
comics I got out of a loot crate like
two years ago and before I got rid of
loot crate Oh No maybe it was the Marvel
box I think I got rid of the Marvel
subscription service but um okay so so
first things first for about the first
minute or so it'll be spoiler free just
because this it's the end credits
explained so you can't do that without
it being spoiler so if you don't want
spoilers the spoiler free version is
that the movies amazing it's it's good
one of the big concerns people had is
that there would be a lot of comedy in
it and to be honest I don't really see a
problem with a lot of comedy I mean it's
it's not an insane amount of comedy yes
it's not like it's a slapstick though it
feels a lot like the guardians of the
galaxy just in terms of the the comedic
feel but it's really really good like
it's really really enjoyable um having
said that I mean there are a few things
that I would have changed here and there
myself and Benny over comic story or
uploading a our opinions our thoughts on
thor ragnarok which is coming out today
but but no I mean it's it's it's
oh I mean it's interesting for what it
is you know I I definitely enjoyed it I
mean it's it's it's it's clearly a movie
worth going to see it's worth every bit
of the 90 some odd percent of aval
rating that I got on Rotten Tomatoes you
know there's a lot of company but here's
the thing though like you gotta also
keep in mind like you can't just look at
the inn you can't just look at Thor
Ragnarok and I know it self you have to
look at the entirety of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe because this is
probably the last little bit of comedy
won't it before things get exceedingly
dark things
assuming Infinity Ward goes the way that
I think it will things will get really
really dark which brings us into the in
credit scene for Thor so this is when we
start getting into the spoilers you know
relatively spoiler free this is when we
start getting into the whole idea of the
you're not gonna ruin too much but when
it comes to when it comes to the end
credits scene I personally think I
personally think that Loki's going to
die in infinity war I think he's I think
he's gonna die it's it's really cool
because you know this this is what we
you know this is the spoiler aspects
from this point going on we're getting
to spoilers but we can't we can't dance
around the non-spoiler thing so I'll
give you guys what like maybe three or
four seconds one two three four okay
spoilers alright so um the funny thing
about math or Ragnarok is it as a blend
between the events of Planet Hulk and
Thor Ragnarok is basically this idea
that it is the attempt of Thor to keep
hella who's basically a sister from
conquering Asgard the funny thing is
that in order for it to happen they have
to let Ragnarok take place and so
because of this it is interesting in
terms of how it unfolds because at the
end they end up having to take the crown
of Surtur and throw it into the eternal
flame and then sort of obliterates
Asgard in its entirety but on the way
there Loki grabs the helmet of Surtur
he's the one that throws it into the
eternal fire but he stops and he looks
at the tesseract at the Cosmic Cube
that's in Asgard and that's the cool
thing about it because it sets the stage
for the idea
that loki is going to have the whole
robbed core it's wrong it's robbed
course like cor PS people just called it
people just felt like core for some
reason but it's cor PS like marine core
something like that so anyway loki grabs
the the helmet of Surtur and throws it
in the eternal flame that brings sir
back to full form sort of you know lays
waste to all of Asgard loki grabs a
cosmic cube and it was cool because it
basically means that going into infinity
war loki will have the Cosmic Cube now
here's the idea the mid of the there's
two credits sees there's the mid-credits
scene and the end credits scene the big
kind of scenes what we care about that's
the only one that matters the end
credits scene is well you know it's it's
whatever it's kind of interesting it
deals with a grandmaster is not
explicitly intriguing but what this does
is it basically says that they're going
to essentially rebuild Asgard on earth
the whole idea is it will probably be in
Norway there was just so much reference
like so much harping on the the aspect
of Norway and in the comma that's where
things get really kind of interesting is
because of the fact that when it comes
to the comics there are huge differences
between the events of Ragnarok and you
know as this in the movie and the comics
is so it's still intriguing it's still
really interesting but for me it's just
one of those weird scenarios because you
basically run into this situation where
in the comics they rebuilt Asgard in
Broxton Oklahoma but in comics loki was
the one who initiated a scar he's the
one that did like the like marched all
the enemies of Asgard on to has guard
itself conquered it killed everybody and
then thor was one of like the last few
heroes left and that was really about it
so the comics are vastly different from
the film i mean it's it's you know this
the film really doesn't pull on the
comics version of Ragnarok nor does it
pull on the Norse mythological version
of Ragnarok it's really kind of its own
hybrid in a lot of different ways it's
cool but it's kind of like its own
hybrid in a lot of different ways that
being said I think that what we're gonna
end up having is
Asgard rebuilt in Norway on earth and
then Thanos showing up on earth during
the events of infinity war and I think
what that's going to be is big
my dogs not hi max is not he's not he's
not hi max is fine um I think that what
infinity war is going to be is max are
you okay
max that's my buddy yeah see max is
wagging his tail he's fine um what it's
going to be it's basically siege on
Asgard
um the siege on Asgard was a really
really cool story and that's why that's
why all this stuff matters that's why
you know all this stuff is really kind
of kind of relevant the siege on Asgard
matters because it's basically an
attempt by the villain Norman Osborn the
Green Goblin who became the new director
of shield to conquer has guard is really
it but with regards to the film I think
that infinity war is going to have
Thanos and all of his forces marching on
Asgard itself and that's the cool thing
is because unlike the comics where
everybody died everybody's like
basically everybody actually every
single Asgardian everywhere was dead at
the end of Ragnarok in the comp I'm
sorry in the film it's a whole bunch of
masks accordions are saved alongside
Thor and Loki so like well we'll just
take our people to earth and everything
will be fine um in the middle of this
when they're like hey man nothing Bad's
gonna happen everything is gonna be okay
tying into the whole comedic element
this ship of Thanos shows up and it's
cool because it's basically Thanos and
the Black Order
now here's what here's a funny thing
about this here's what's so cool about
all this truth to tell Thanos and the
Black Order will probably decimate Thor
and Loki I mean I have a hard time
believing they what like I have a hard
time believing they wouldn't be able to
obliterate you know Thor and Loki I mean
it's it's the Black Order I mean you're
talking about like Proxima midnight core
Corvus glaive the ebony maw dam who was
the last one um supergiant I mean you're
talking about some pretty powerful guys
in terms of what they can do and so it's
cool because I think that's going to be
the first stage in basically this
statement of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe all hope is lost for the
superheroes I mean if you have Thor and
Loki who have just survived Ragnarok and
like Thanos and the Black Order show up
and then like all know my friends your
troubles are just beginning like I think
it's I
it's gonna be cool I think it's gonna be
interesting I think Ragnarok I think as
Mark will be built I think that Ragnarok
I'm sorry that Asgard may actually be
built on earth I have no idea
most likely it'll be Thor and Loki just
like rushing back to earth and just
being like hey guys or it'll probably be
that they get totally like crushed and
obliterated I haven't seen the trailer
for four infinity war yet so I don't
really know what they give away my guess
is that my guess is that thanos tsantas
guys are gonna show up on the ship with
Loki and Thor and kill all the other
kill all the Asgardians that are left I
think that'll fulfill the other half of
Ragnarok because remember then Ragnarok
in Norse mythology it's basically the
end of the Asgardian it's the death of
all the Asgardians everything's gone
that's it there's nothing left in the
comics it was much the same way I think
the fans in this black order are going
to eradicate all that's left of the sea
Lando lambda Z bro I think it's not
pronounced that you deserve this you are
an awesome dude and keep keeping Jerr I
appreciate it man thank you I appreciate
that a lot I mean super chats are always
welcome guys so it's it's always
appreciated but I definitely appreciate
that um no I think that they're gonna
show up they're gonna kill all the
Asgardians they're going to either take
Loki captive or Loki's going to escape
and then I think Thor is probably gonna
try to fight them and either Thor will
die or Thor will be like
defeated my hope my hope is that like
Thor gets rekt and just said flying out
into space and like finds the guardians
of the galaxy now that would be like a
great a great way to tie in because you
got Thor those guys just floating in
space nobody else is in space right now
except for Thor Loki the Asgardians in
the guardians of the galaxy and all that
I think I think I said guarding the
universe
guardians of the galaxy I don't know I
mean I think it'd be kind of cool you
know regardless hopefully Thor could be
the more that bridge that gap but the
whole idea to me is that with aspirin
presumably being rebuilt on our
somewhere along the line it basically
offers an extension of what happens in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
it allows Asgard and all those things to
continue on but that's the big question
it's like where do things go from here
like what's the next step in the model
Cinematic Universe again you know if if
we have battles in the black order show
up they kill all the
guardians Loki escapes is basically all
hell breaks loose you know in this total
pandemonium
that's a really dark statement in the
MCU because you know again like I think
that the entirety of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is gonna get really
really dark from this point going
forward a lot of time I think is gonna
happen but I don't know I mean at this
point is really anybody's game which is
kind of speculation it's just kind of
filling it out there and trying to
figure it out and that's that's really
about it I mean there's not a whole lot
to go on in terms of what we have um oh
also okay so here's the deal baby over a
comic story had told me yesterday that
apparently because of the front because
of the fact that Universal owns the
rights to the Incredible Hulk that
Marvel cannot actually make Incredible
Hulk standalone films or at the very
least the rights are in such a state of
flux that Marvel Dina doesn't want you
or cannot make a standalone film
regardless of what the scenario is The
Incredible Hulk is gonna have a story
that's going to be told in the form of a
trilogy over the course of the next few
films I believe I believe that infinity
war is going to be World War Hall that
it's gonna be the World War Hulk story
alright and here's why so in the comics
the Incredible Hulk was sent to Planet
Hulk into saqar because the earth
superheroes deemed him too dangerous of
a threat for the earth he was too
uncontrollable so they set him away from
Earth he crash-landed on Saqqara when he
wasn't supposed to became a gladiator
top of the existing King found the wife
his wife that everybody died in the
explosion when his ship was basically
you know when the nuclear drive the ship
was detonated and he came back to earth
just totally pissed I mean he was so
pissed off alright so we know like from
the least room what I've seen in the
castings anyway from the cast cast
listings Oh Liv Tyler is going to be in
infinity war Liv Tyler is Betty Ross Liv
Tyler I think is going to die and the
assault on Thanos and I think that
infinity war I think here's not exactly
how infinity war is gonna play out I
think infinity war is going to be Thanos
showing up on earth in an attempt to
capture the Infinity stones just you
know capture the tesseract that Loki
might have or whatever the case may be
or capture like the mind stone from
vision no I haven't seen I know the
trailers out there but I've been waiting
for the official drop of the trailer in
order to see it um I think that the
analyst is going to show up on earth
looking for like because we know the
mine stones
we know the time stones there so like we
know the analyst has reason to show up
on earth
I think Fanus is gonna show up on earth
I think Danis is going to capture the
mind stone so vision is gonna be gone
I think he's gonna capture the time
stone from Doctor Strange and I think in
the attack Liv Tyler's gonna die Betty
Ross is gonna be killed and I think that
when Betty Ross dies Hulk is gonna lose
it and he's just gonna become like a
universe like a planet-wide threat and
so World War Hulk will basically be like
Thanos showing up Abby like I got my
gems and then Hulk just loses his mind
when left Tyler dies so he's just like
I'm out and they just bail they just
take off most likely she'll die at the
hands of like the of the Black Order or
something along those lines
yeah but like like Betty Ross means more
to the Incredible Hulk I would have to
believe any wages from what we've seen
in the movies Betty Ross means more to
the Incredible Hulk than like Black
Widow does like black widows a chick
where she's like hey big fella
this Suns getting low like like what Oh
sucks
no she doesn't she was a suck but I
think many Ross means a lot more to the
Hulk and Black Widow does and so I think
Betty Ross dying presumably at the hands
of the like order will probably lead to
the black border being totally
obliterated by Hulk like Rome or Hulk
will just go on a rampage kill everybody
in the black order and then just keep on
getting angry and angry and then just
become a threat to the earth and I think
that in that moment Santos would just be
like I got my gems and he just he just
takes off he just bails out grabs the
Infinity stones leaves and then the rest
of the movie is the Incredible Hulk
losing his mind on earth and basically
obliterating the entirety of the earth
from there I think it'll lead into the
second Avengers film which is basically
going to be the story of Infinity
Gauntlet and that's when things are
really gonna pop off that's my
speculation that's my idea but keep in
mind guys like Thanos vs. Hulk is a
weird discussion it's a weird topic
because Marvel has done it in a couple
different ways for example in the
original Infinity Gauntlet story
Thanos just totally overpowered the Hulk
but he also had the power stone but then
if you go and you read a fan oohs versus
Hulk like Thanos makes it I'm sorry not
that most versus Hulk um I think it's
that hose I think it's Thanos versus
hope Santos makes his statement that he
routinely tries to avoid the Incredible
Hulk because of how powerful he is
so I don't know I mean it's it's it's
kind of weird I mean in my personal
opinion
danos would probably wreck be Incredible
Hulk to a point I don't think that also
be able to kill him
but I think they must be able to wreck
the Incredible Hulk and to the Hulk got
powerful enough and then just like loses
his mind on him you know and then then
that would be the end of Thanos uh but
you know I don't know I mean let's see
uh
okay so let's answer questions that you
guys have because we've kind of been
ranting for about about you know 15
minutes so let's let's talk about the
questions that you guys have so um let's
see so who has the soul stone from Thor
3 uh well we've got 1,100 we've got
about as many people as we're gonna get
in here about 1,100 people um right now
the person with the soul well I don't
think anybody has a soul stone
um nevermind I was thinking of the space
stone I was thinking of the you know
space stuff who has a soul stone I think
Black Panther has a soul stone
and I think the soul stone is the manner
by which Black Panther and all the Black
Panthers have used to communicate with
the with the the former Black Panthers
alright so here's the deal in Marvel
Comics um
Black Panther was largely just it was
just black panther he was just a guy
that spoke with you know the Panther got
best and that was it it wasn't until
Jonathan Hickman came along I think and
he wrote Avengers and New Avengers that
he introduced the Necropolis and the
metropolis is where Black Panther came
commune with everyone who's ever been a
black panther basically the souls of his
of his ancestors um I think that what
Marvel's gonna do at the end Marvel
Cinematic Universe what they're gonna do
is they're gonna take the soul stone and
they're gonna take the concept of soul
world which is basically this dimension
this world that exists inside the soul
infinity stone I think they're gonna
roll that into Black Panther and on
through they're gonna say the Panther
God bass resides within the soul stone
and that all the individuals who have
ever been Black Panther reside within
soul world and I think that that's gonna
be like the soul stone is gonna be how
it is that Black Panther you know
T'Challa communicates with those guys
that's my thought but I think it belongs
to Black Panther so uh hey big guy
this Suns getting real low I'll be
honest I know it wasn't meant to be
funny but during
events of age of Ultron would that
happen like I just started laughing I
was in the theater I just started
laughing I was like Black Widow is one
of the most like one of the greatest
assassins in the entirety of the Marvel
Universe like she is a world-class
assassin she could kill virtually
anybody she wants to and that's what you
do with her character she calls banner
day what a waste it was it was silly and
it was ridiculous um but no yeah I think
like Mather has the I think like Mather
is where we'll see the soul stone so um
let's see well everyone diné bá
cliffhanger for part 1 of Infinity Ward
I think that a cliffhanger for infinity
war will be Thanos gathering finally
gathering all the Infinity stones and I
think he's going I think he's legit
going to try to impress mistress death I
think that mistress death is there like
I don't I do not believe hella is
mistress death um I believe that like
mistress death is an actual being and I
think this will be the first time we see
remember like no character ever has the
debut until they're they're like
mistress death was never teased it was
never liked in Marvel Comics
you had mistress death who you know they
were just kind of teasing her you know
and that kind of thing she was just
there one day it was iron man now you're
Iron Man number 75 I think it was
roughed up my head but it was when when
Thanos first appeared in Marvel Comics
and it was basically him no I'm sorry it
was yeah when that was himself first
appeared him over how much and he was
they were accompanied by mistress death
um I think mistress death is there
I think mr. Snaith is in the background
I think we just haven't seen her yet um
but I think dennis is very much driving
to gain her affections and so yeah I
think of the the cliffhanger for
infinity war will be Thanos snapping his
fingers and blinking out half the life
in the universe I think that's going to
be the I think that's gonna be the
cliffhanger for infinity war um yeah
exactly
Nova someone knows what's up know was
not before 20 know what's out there they
know what's up um yeah hella and misters
death are two distinctly different
characters okay guys so here was a deal
but so Stan Lee and Jack Kirby never
really believed in the idea of killing
characters that was never really their
thing for the most part they focused on
like light-hearted superhero stories it
was hey like let's make coming butch an
escape as opposed to like a reflection
of the real world now writers
Chris Claremont did that and it was done
exceedingly well you know he did a
really good reflection of the real world
in terms of soap operas dramas
interpersonal relationships between
characters love triangles different
things like that but um Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby just wanted to have just one
of this health fun stories and so
because of the fact that Thor was
introduced uh you know with the Norse
mythology being back up features we got
help because he'll ever I guess really
hell's is her character's name she is a
character from Norse mythology she's the
ruler of you know basically what amounts
to the afterlife for for those in Asgard
and you know normal people and so on and
so forth
but because of the fact that Marvel took
the north's mythological concept of pala
and applied it to comics what it meant
is that those individuals who died
honorably in the name of Asgard meaning
they believed in Asgard and they died in
battle they go to Valhalla those
individuals who just died for whatever
reason they just didn't they they died
not believing in Asgard and not you know
in in battle not in the glory of battle
they basically went to the realm of
hella and that was it that's all there
was you know if you or I or anybody
lived in the Marvel Universe back when
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby were writing we
would go to the afterlife to the realm
of hella the problem with this was that
about nine years after hella appeared I
want to say in 1974 at 225 around nine
years after hella up here mistress death
appeared and that was Marvel's answer to
where do people go when they die will
they go to the realm of mistress death
and it created confusion the question
was okay well do they go to the realm of
Halle or do they go to the realm of
mistress death because they were
established to be two distinctly
different characters hella was on an
aspect of mistress death it's not like
you know mistress death decided to take
a break and just walk around as hell on
one day it doesn't work that way like
they're two totally different characters
from two totally different realms and
that's the way it works in Marvel um
it's been modified basically to the
point that those who believe in Asgard
but did not die an honorable combat go
to the realm of hella those who believe
in Asgard and did die in honorable
combat
go to Valhalla those individuals who
just regular people go to the realm of
mistress death people who were tricked
by Mephisto have their souls taken by
Mephisto when they die and they go to
his room
Marvel is basically sort of gone through
and organized it to a degree but they
haven't like it's not
there's a chart that tells you that
right there's not like a handbook that
tells you like you know how it all works
you know if you go read like the Marvel
encyclopedia or whatever it is the
Marvel handbook guidebook whatever it'll
just say hella where she takes the
Warriors that like we should take those
who like the souls of this up the debt
and then mistress death who takes the
souls of the dead it's just there's no
real clear concise explanation there but
nonetheless you know it's just one of
those weird one of those weird things so
um let's see Zach Dixon I think it'll be
Doctor Strange using the time stone that
homestead owes off while phase four
happens um I think he could probably
hold him off I could see that being the
case but it won't last
I think ultimately he'll be taken down
so um let's see the two characters don't
have any yeah exactly man of action
that's exactly right
perfect answer um let's see uh yeah yeah
oh yeah boy 998 let's see a cliffhanger
for infinity war everybody dies and
Kappa symbols the rest of the team maybe
I have no idea or just as symbols what's
left I mean that would be kind of a cool
a cool thing um let's see uh sorcerer
supreme or sorcerer sorcerer extreme do
you think the cartoons games give give
away the story like the future fight
scenes with dr. strange no I don't think
so not the only thing that gives
anything away not at all so uh the three
trucker story has not been fleshed out
yet it's supposed to be but it's not
been fleshed out yet so um Carlos arrow
with the Inhumans now having their own
series do you think that they will do in
Illuminati formation nope I think the
Inhumans have their own series and I
think that series is going to come to an
end and I think we'll see neither hide
nor hair of the Inhumans again they will
just be gone forever no one and no one
will ever ask what happened to them
no one will ever say whatever happened
to the Inhumans they'll just those never
be talked about again so uh let's see yo
ya'll it's matt i think i apologize if i
if i pronounced that wrong hey Brad
how's the new pod two more questions one
where do you get your awesome music for
your vids two venom Vader vs vs Deadpool
with Thor's hammer
Deadpool what Thor's hammer would
clearly no venom Bane will probably win
because of the fact that he's got the
force
Andie's let'em and then I get my music
from epidemic sound which is just
epidemic sound calm um but yeah that's
that's where I get my stuff from my
editor just grabs it throws it all in
there I just tell him to make sure he
uses music in the compliments the videos
sometimes you know sometimes he doesn't
I mean at this point I think people are
more for their story as opposed to the
your music but um but ya know the new
okay so I'm just renting this place for
right now which is why it's so dated
mine does not load the house and I'm I'm
closing on the 9th by the way November
9th 1 p.m. I closed on my house my house
is not nearly this big my house was
built recently it wasn't built in you
know 30 years ago so I definitely wanted
more of a blend between a more modern
feel and a classic feel so the house
that I'm buying definitely has that has
that feel to it um let's see ah his
Bruce Banner dead no um
who wins Thor Hawk well for was
originally designed to be a counter to
the Hulk
people say Thor was designed to kill the
whole cur to defeat the Hulk I'm not
sure that's true I mean there's an
interview where Stan load or Stan Lee
says it well then it's Stan Lee's the
one that made him so he's the one that
can specify under what situations Thor
was originally created because they were
the ones who made him in the comics so I
mean I feel like only a fool would argue
with that uh yeah so a frog Thor yeah we
need to make a throg video yeah we need
to make that frog Thor
life Thor becomes a frog frog it's funny
because it is actually a prank that
lumpy pools on Thor and it's funny it's
like this drawn out like six-issue story
arc it's kind of crazy um let's see
what's my background I was a dispatcher
before I became a youtuber kind of crazy
huh world's the world's a wild place
okay and here's something that I'm gonna
pick y'all's brains all of you who are
watching this right now all right and
leave a comment if you will please
because I want to know this is something
you would want to see all right I'm
experimenting with the idea of creating
like a short film about 20 minutes long
and it's gonna Center on comics torreón
and then I'll make one about myself but
it's basically how we got to where we
are and like it for him it'll be like
how how much story I got to where he is
and like what life is like as a youtuber
and then the same thing will be for me
like how I got to where I am and what
life is like as a youtuber like I want
to make that and then branch it out and
like hopefully get other youtubers to do
it but let me know if that's something
that you guys would want to see so
who do you think is a scroll Rob as far
as I know they're not going with Secret
Invasion for the Carol Danvers Captain
Marvel movie I could be wrong but as far
as I know that's not gonna happen
accord video honestly we could do a
court video but basically anything you
need to know about Court is covered in
my Incredible Hulk series it's covered
in Planet Hulk World War Hulk all that
kind of stuff so um let's see uh an
origin story for for throg yeah do you
like an origin story Wonder story for
myself yeah I guess yeah it would be uh
yeah you tumor organs they'd be a cool
name um it sounds pretty intriguing uh
let's see
do you have a story explaining the
entire DC multiverse okay so here's the
deal with a whole like history of the DC
universe um I initially started it the
problem was that almost immediately or
almost again almost immediately after I
started doing that DC rebirth was
kicking off and right off the bat there
were a massive changes that were being
made to the DC Universe and it seems
like basically DC rebirth is just coming
along and changing up a ton of stuff so
when the dust settles we'll go back and
do that because what I don't want to do
is create a history of the DC Universe
and then turn around and have to and
people just be like be totally confused
because what they're reading in the
comics is starkly different from what
there's what was actually like what I'm
telling them so I basically want to wait
until the dust settles after DC rebirth
and then go back and finish it so um
let's see oh you know much by Thor video
net let's see uh Express Express robbery
up here
hello destroying the hammer thoughts
okay well that comes from the trailer so
that's not a spoiler of any kind um
hello destroy the hammer is actually
kind of cool all right here's a question
that I want to know from you guys
because obviously Thor throws it at her
which is why why gets destroyed my
question and actually the events of the
movie play out differently from what you
saw in the trailer but what I want to
know is is how you guys how you guys
think the hammer like why you guys did
the hammer was destroyed
I think the hammer was destroyed because
Thor threw it and the hammer will keep
going in that direction until for
recalls it and Thor never recall it he
just threw it at hella and her it was
basically an
before smeeting an immovable object and
she was just more powerful in the hammer
and so as a result the Hammers own
momentum led to its own destruction I'm
kind of curious let me know how you guys
feel about that that's that's my thought
on how it happened so um let's say do
you think Batman worth do I think Batman
white knight is worth reading absolutely
it is an amazing story it's insanely
good Phillip Ward and $5.00 thank you
off-topic but I was hoping you could do
a try on juggernaut or eight-day
juggernaut story yes I want to I
definitely wanna do the eighth day
storyline because it is a really really
cool storyline like it is it is pretty
solid so my dog looks tired home and
yeah I mean he's just loved him that's
all he ever does is just loaf around I
mean he was like we were up and like he
went for a walk and played outside
everything earlier so he's just kind of
tired now but um let's see this Thor had
the Thor force now uh yeah kind of it's
kind of weird but yeah he hasn't um
let's see do you think oh wow the red
samurai um okay thank you for five bucks
scott snyder asked on twitter which
characters people would like to see more
uh who would like to see Rob uh who
would I like to see okay you want Jon
Stewart hot girls in Legion um probably
more job well no we get a lot of Jon
Stewart the house worked on the Green
Lantern Corps um I mean I don't know I
mean I think the way he's pacing it
right now it's pretty solid I mean is he
asking in general for DC or just for his
a lot of stories because the visit of
general for DC the character I want to
see more of is Shazam that's who I want
to see more of like I want to know where
he went to so uh what did I think of
Serdar I thought serda was cool
I thought sort of was you was used just
enough so that you know how dangerous he
is but not so much that he loses the
effect of being Surtur the destroyer of
gods um I felt like he was used just the
right amount like just perfectly so um
let's see are you uh are you the guy on
the boat and spot no I'm not the guy on
the boat it's finally yeah spider-man
that would be cool but no I'm not I'm
not that guy um let's see
uh give that give that dog ten cc's or
belly rubs for being a good one oh yeah
he gets yeah he gets she goes belly runs
all the time now a funny thing is also
giving him belly rubs and it might take
my hand away he'll reach out and grab my
hand and pull it back it's kind of funny
so um let's see uh dark side is coming
after you which Marvel hero do you
choose to protect you Galactus let's see
do you think what do I think happened to
SIF and Thor Ragnarok sips never as if
it has not been seen or heard from for
quite some time I have no idea what's
going on with SIF maybe she's dead I
have no clue uh yeah I don't know I mean
it's it's yeah she's been gone for a
little while um okay so so overall I
mean we're gonna wrap this up cause like
I said it's a quick Q&A so overall um I
really I really really enjoyed okay
Robert Robert Robert how do you think
Black Panther will go
I think Black Panther will go awesome I
think it'll definitely be one of the
coolest movies of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I think it'll be one of the
most unique I think it'll probably be
the most unique no not think about it
because people I think they think of
when they hear Black Panther lives in
what Conda
they think of like tribes with you know
straw huts and things like that not to
say they're I mean they're not racist or
anything it's just how they perceive it
because that's largely how you view real
world like different African territories
um but in terms of like Black Panther
you're gonna see like a stupid
technologically advanced society way
beyond anything you see in the rest of
the world so like it's gonna be nuts
it's gonna be crazy it's really gonna
bobble them on and I think people are
gonna be like why doesn't the rest of
the world have technology like this like
it's gonna seem like a world unto itself
hundreds of years into the future so
it's gonna be what may be the hundreds
of years but like decades into the
future it's gonna be pretty solid so
what do you think of the actor director
of Korg I loved quark as a character I
thought it was great people who are
traditional fans of quark are gonna hate
him
but I loved I loved the character of
Thor of the court I'm not so entrenched
in the comics that I don't like change
um I'm really dig like I love the
character of course so I'm pretty happy
with what they did with him but anyway
guys overall movie was amazing
definitely worth a go see it is it's
definitely something you have to go
check out so
when's the housewarming well the house
I'm gonna have I'm gonna take mini and
then bye once I get moved or once I once
I close and everything but there's some
changes that I'm gonna make like I'm
gonna tear up a hardwood put down
hardwood floors or a tear up the carpet
put down hardwood floors on tear out the
existing entertainment center put it in
a new one there's some changes that I'm
gonna make to that house the house woman
probably won't be in till after the turn
of the year but yeah it'll be it'll be a
little while they have a they have two
inches into the kitchen one is in a wall
that looks like it was just artificially
made so I'm gonna fill that in and get
rid of that but uh but yeah so anyway
definitely go check out the work guys an
incredible film definitely worth
watching one of my absolute favorite
films so far it's pretty solid
I mean it's yes it has comedy but it
adds to the movie it doesn't take away
it is it's it's pretty cool it's pretty
great so far so anyway guys ready to go
and bring this to an end thanks for
coming out of your body for for you know
showing up in the the Q&A session and
everything and I will catch you all
later please